I think liberals they just they they
make a real effort not to understand the
Trump voter and
um you know it's like oh just dance is
going to be great because he's it's
trumpism without Trump and I think
they're like why would we want a tribute
band
sure bands still playing
I agree 100 yes DeSantis can fill a room
but he can fill it with the kind of
energy you want to then leave the room
like he's he does not have the warrants
but on top of it the the thing that so I
went back a couple weeks ago
you guys remember the first debate in
2015 it's August 2015 right and so the
Republic everybody's like what what the
hell is about to happen so they did the
junior debate first it was the seven
Republicans who didn't get to like five
percent then they bring them all out
10 guys
first question to all 10 of them was
who will raise their hand and say that
they won't support the nominee no matter
who it is
Trump raises him and the crowd Boos they
I mean a Lusty boo
and it's like watching the the five
seconds before Pompeii goes off before
the because what then happens is they're
booing and Trump not a word gives a
gesture he gives the Trump face which is
like are you kidding me these
Jokers around me and you can actually
hear the crowd turn from a Buddha to a
shriek of Joy because he's the
transgressor he's Johnny Rotten of the
Republican party you will not find
anybody who delivers for this he's
better than him he's why there's a
certain Clique in high school and you
don't understand why are they the cool
kids they have confidence
and the rest of us are insecure I don't
think that's going to work again that
worked for a long time he's got an
amazing Charisma that kind of towel
snapping business that he does but
I have a hard time believing that there
isn't a critical mass of people who
wouldn't go for somebody who believes in
the sorts of things that he
unfortunately believes in but also seems
like he would rule as a grown-up and by
descent is filling a room I mean that
some people have said to me that he
actually gives a good speech now I don't
think he'll ever light up a room the way
Trump did but wouldn't people maybe
prefer the tribute band rather than
somebody who's going to blow up the
world no I hope so no I I I I hope so
too but it's uh I I I was even more on
the side of what I'm saying now this
week when we found out how much Fox News
has been lying and I thought see my
liberal mind went to oh my God you you
Fox News viewers all you care about is
fake news and now we have you caught
red-handed that you are getting fake
news we have this evidence they're
caught red-handed talking we have the
transcripts the emails the texts they're
saying they hate Trump he's bad for the
country they know he lost the country
and they're telling you the exact
opposite aren't you dumbasses a
understand and there's going yeah we
know but it just feels right it feels
good and I need to feel good and it
doesn't matter if it's factually right
it's like you know what remember the OJ
trial like black folks knew that OJ
killed that girl to a man right but it
just felt right and I don't blame them
what for once a black guy beat the
justice system after a zillion times the
other way around so you think people are
going to watch Tucker Carlson and Laura
Ingram lying to them but figure well
that's okay because we want to get back
at people who look down yes yes
absolutely yes that's exactly it and the
idea that people want oh but but he has
some of the uh the policies that we love
so much about Trump they don't care
about the policies they care about the
guys they don't even care about the
lying I mean Tucker Carlson is now
caught saying I hate Trump passionately
and I thought when I always this
you got they got you and then I
realized and I've quoted this before
some conservative guy I know said to me
sometime ago what you people don't get
about the Micah crowd is we don't like
him either
and then I read this other thing Trump
said a couple of weeks ago where he said
they're not out to get me they're about
to get you they're coming for you they
just got to get through me that's what
they like about him he's a warrior